I've had my fish hole running for a few
hours now I'll be at home taking care of
the dogs been some other chores coming
back here check it see what I'm catching
this is a big thing for me because it's
going to relieve me financially and it's
going to provide my dogs with an
excellent food source
Ollie good tonight is my home this way
it is up here you know you set a goal
you stick to it and you work hard
River takes care of you as long as you
respect it seven keep track keep track
of my number so I can fill them out on
my paperwork keep fishing game posted
it's eight big males and ten females
right there of the salmon species it's a
lot of good fish right there I never let
my dogs go hungry but I know how
valuable of resources is that's why I
strive to do this going back gonna get
my cooker fired up cook these up for the
dogs while that's going on I'm gonna
play up these and start my grill too I
work hard to feed my dogs they like
provide this food myself is like a very
rewarding feeling to me it ties in the
whole lifestyle of like being in Alaska
and not just being a dog sure it's more
important for me the lifestyle I like to
tie it in all together be
self-sufficient productive this is true
freedom right here like seeing these
dogs being happy you know means
everything to me
I like being out here you know no place
I'd rather be no life I'd rather be
living I'm all about it